so I'm actually honored to be moderating
our next panel and it'll be about
positive change and the power of data
today we are witnessing the
unprecedented intersection of the power
of data and technology and we find
ourselves capable of incredible change
it's a theme and as a global community
we can train our innovative sites on the
biggest targets healthcare finance the
environment even human intelligence
itself how can we do this
meaningfully I'll be joined by panelists
today Daniel craft who's MDE founder and
chair of exponential medicine at
singularity tre Vassallo co-founder and
Managing Director at defied me see and
danny lang vice-president AI and machine
learning at Unity Technologies please
join me and join me in welcoming our
panelists
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so I thought I start with a
little bit of an introduction just in
case that those titles were not
meaningful enough Daniel was a Stanford
and Harvard trained physician scientist
biotech and clinical researcher
innovator and entrepreneur amazing many
hats he's chair of medicine at
singularity University and founder and
chair of exponential medicine he's a
sought-after speaker on the quantified
self and quantified health and we'll
talk a little bit of what that means
Trey is co-founder and Managing Director
at defied VC she's an engineer an
entrepreneur and an investor and her
passion is collaborating with the
world's best entrepreneurs and now at
defy she's co-founder and Managing
Director and previously she was an
early-stage venture capital as Arie she
was previously at general partner at
Kleiner Perkins Caufield & Byers
and started her career at IDEO danny is
leads machine learning teams that has
led machine learning teams at uber
Amazon Microsoft and IBM before now
leading vai machine learning at Unity
Technologies and if you've ever gotten a
product recommendation at Amazon you've
seen daddy's work the same goes for all
that you beret I that books your rides
we can ask him questions about that we
have time
he's now bringing the wonders of AI and
machine learning to the world of gaming
in AR and VR so I want to start actually
with Daniel quantified self quantified
health what are you measuring today are
you devices what have you measured I
measure most my lack of sleep I've got
almost two-year-old it keeps getting up
at 5:00 a.m. and I'm you know there's
always new wearables everything to ringa
bowls to sleepable this one actually is
a little ring out of Finland that will
track sleep pretty well and give you a
bit of a score and track your time and
REM and light and deep that's just one
of the things you can have measure with
a sensor in your mattress to your
fitbit's Apple watches and wear I think
this is sort of heading on that sort of
big data piece is that we're going from
the quantify itself a lot of us are data
geeks we might measure this on our
phones and keep the data locally
if I itself to quantify it health
meaning it's going to start playing a
role in hopefully nudging you in the
right direction to stay proactively
healthy and optimize well-being and then
move us to doing earlier diagnostics or
managing disease so in this internet
have connected medical things and their
big data machine learning we're gonna
start to make sense of this
digital exhaust and and hopefully
transform health medicine is there too
much information at any given time well
it can't be and no one wants to
necessarily whether it's you or your
your physician as of the last year you
can now connect least through my Apple
phone into my medical record at Stanford
and my clinician could even see my sort
of wearable data the trick is how do you
make sense no one wants to see the raw
data about your steps in your sleeps and
how many how many stairs you'd climb but
how do you synthesize that how do you
give yourself a personal check engine
light or that your clinical team can see
to give you early warning and that's
that's where I think sort of things need
to head in to be actual information not
overwhelming and we're still learning
what how to make sense of of all those
signals got it
including the genomics level that
overlay is at your behavioral
information it's not just vital signs it
could be the sort of integration amazing
tre you're known for spotting the next
big thing you've led early investments
and Dropcam and nest where are you
making big bets where do you think the
next opportunities are okay well that's
a big question maybe I will build on
that a little bit with this point of you
know technology investing used to be
called investing in information
technology and so it really is about
data and the crazy thing that's been
happening is that the the machines that
allow us to detect and then crunch and
then send out and share that data have
gone from you know these machines these
massive servers to know these things
that live in our pockets and on our
bodies so the thing that I'm
particularly excited about is how we're
turning all the important things in our
lives
massive physical objects into computing
platforms and many of you in this room
are doing exactly that by turning the
car into a computing platform and with
nest and Dropcam you know the thesis was
really the house also needs to be a
computing platform what is the you know
what are going to be the interaction
modalities for that and we're super
super early days we're starting to see
things like voice obviously taking off
and being one of the modalities by which
people are starting to intersect with
with the the world around them another
big place that is really important to
turning these platforms into two
valuable things for us going forward is
you have to have sensors so how you're
getting this data that previously was
unaccessible to us is quite valuable so
there's a lot of focus going into things
like cameras like different types of
sensors and so packaging that sensor
data then packaging these you know
really low cost ubiquitous computing
platforms and then ultimately I always
say that you know investing in data or
in technology is not what I do I invest
in solving problems so ultimately the
key for for us as investors is figuring
out what are the great important
problems that I should be focused on and
then how do I use data and technology in
new and different ways to solve that
problem in the best way I can
it's wonderful so Danny turning to you
you we're not talking specifically about
AI but it's predicated on large data and
what does it really mean to have
meaningful enough data for AI right
what's what's the difference between
human learning machine learning where
does it get to machine learning yeah
there's no secret that that large amount
of data the availability of large amount
of data has really revolutionized AI and
really moved a lot of the the work that
we previously called data science into
the realm of automation and what I'm
particularly focused on is to to think
about creating the loop between AI and
the world by basically creating a
feedback mechanism where you feed data
back to the system and the system
constantly measure measure the outcome
of its actions yeah and this is very
much the way that that the world nature
has worked here
that's how we learn by basically
interacting with the environment and see
look at the outcomes and learn from them
and I think that that's that's what what
I'm pushing towards when it comes to the
marriage of data and AI that is to
create that loop so I think when we're
getting ready for this panel we talked a
lot about what do we hope you guys all
take away from this so beyond the
inspirations beyond some thoughts
starters we actually want you to also
take away some of the kind of soft
skills right so what Trey was talking
about it's not just about the skills
it's not just about the data but how do
you make that meaningful and how do you
actually solve problems so on that front
you know we were trying to talk about
what is meaningful and related to that
what is ethical I think we've seen a lot
of news recently especially with
Facebook and the power of data and
what's possible with profiling and so
forth
guidance from the team what's meaningful
ethics how do we how do we bound the
power that is beings are freed up for
all our students as they're learning
skills yeah we all start with sort of a
the health care side everyone's sort of
concerned about their digital exhaust or
their potential genomic information and
but there's an incredible power to the
point of having problems to solve and
feedback loops so if we can start to
crowdsource this data and we're all you
know back to the self-driving car or the
Google Maps equivalent you know ten
years ago we still a paper maps now you
couldn't imagine driving with that
Google Maps or ways and you share your
private data your speed and location we
have a map and you can see where the
traffic is that same hopefully mindset
can infuse into health and medicine over
hopefully crowdsourcing our genomic
information that our clinical paths
whether we have the flu or not and while
keeping it hopefully safe and anonymous
sharing it enough to to be a point where
we have really intelligent driven
healthcare because our feedback loops
we're very reactive we have a sick care
model we wait for things to happen and
while maintaining the privacy elements
there's a tremendous opportunity to open
up the doors to speeding up clinical
trials understanding your own individual
information so having you should
hopefully own the information from your
from your genome from your wearable
devices and beyond and opt into sharing
them but there's also the dark side
which we can't
I know this is a really powerful and
important question and I remember when I
invested in Dropcam here we're saying
we're gonna put a camera in your house
that we're gonna monitor 24/7 and we're
gonna record this for you and store it
in the cloud doesn't that sound great
and and there was a lot of concern that
are people ready for this and so you
know I think as we see with all new
technology we have to prove that the
value of having that product in your
life outweighs potential risks that
you're giving up around saying yes take
my data put it into the cloud and I'm
gonna trust that you're gonna handle it
correctly and so there's a lot of trust
that needs to be built on the back end
how you communicate that to your
customers is really important and then
also learning that sometimes these steps
need to be done slowly so consumers
don't always jump to the the final
product in a very easy way and sometimes
there needs to be baby steps so this
notion of us you know now have having
things like Alexa in our house that
really are listening to what we're
saying 24/7 and responding think about
how hard that would have been to
introduce even a few years ago so you
know we're constantly making this
trade-off and I think a lot of this is
an unclear you know how am I gonna feel
about the fact that I've just uploaded
all this data about me no Danny I mean I
can get so excited by not talking about
AI and machining and what's possible
yeah sometimes I get too excited and
that's actually it's important to think
about yeah because we can do things now
that we couldn't do five years ago and
the Liuba just talked about when that
happens in a computer game on an amazon
website or uber when you create that
feedback loop and you have tens a
hundred of millions of players or
customers or users of your service and
the reward signal in that loop comes so
become so important yeah and and and if
that remote signals is just you know get
people to pay more money or some
thing like that yeah then the computer
may very quickly turn you and your
company and your team into something you
actually didn't plan to be yeah so I
always try to to endorse or promote the
idea of having an an Ombuds person on
ethics officer or some input which says
you know is this who we want to be is
more minutes of use as more dollars or
more app clicks is is that who we are
and I think that that that is another
feedback loop you know you we all need
to remember to have because increasingly
we can do more and more and we can do a
lot of things we couldn't imagine until
you know very recently and there will
soon we will be able to do things we
can't imagine today yeah and it doesn't
mean we have to do or should do those
things and we sometimes have trouble
imagining what's only gonna be here in a
couple of years I mean this museum is
perfect all these you know video games
from my past or downstairs and their
antique already and even on the side of
you know Alexis you know they can start
to listen to our voice and pick up
emotional state or York off whether it's
a pneumonia your your dropcam's can now
look at a kid in the sleep sleeping and
now look at the respiratory rate and
their movement but maybe soon pick up
whether they have autism early if you
start a flying machine learning to that
you know who owns that data is it as a
question so things are moving
exponentially it's and quickly at the
convergence that things get exciting
are they any lessons there from medicine
I mean talking about who owns that data
and if someone can help spot those
diseases you know why would we not right
but any lessons I mean I would imagine
an in medicine especially we have you
guys have more guardrails have some sort
of processes or procedures to manage
Riley Kahn ombudsmen equivalent are
there things that we should be thinking
beyond that for for house for the smart
home for the smart city one just piece
you know sometimes the technology moves
faster than our ethics and our
regulatory there's a movie that's twenty
years old called Gattaca which is sort
of exemplifies now our genomics age
we're essentially a 100 dollar genome
today that's a lot of data now we're
gonna room at a below more microbiome
are are expose omar behavioral all those
things are becoming
cheap and easy to get and now you guys
are building the software that can make
sense of that that the challenge is
gonna be who owned again who owns that
who controls it how do we share it in
smart ways and not on some of the
unethical sides any favorite I guess
examples from anyone around how that's
done well or how you've seen examples of
where it's failed hard to tell I would
say I mean I look at my kids right and
they engage with Amazon Alexa in just
ways that I would not expect them to
they engage in gaming right ready player
one comes out tomorrow by the way if
anyone's looking at movies I'm excited
to see the movie but it posits an
incredibly you know data fueled world
right data and art and gaming all that
coming together you know how do you guys
think about that right data informing
art art from forming data start with
Danny yeah yeah I do want to put a plug
in for art I think that in a world with
increased automation there are few
things that are left for humankind to
take care of art is one of them so I
want to draw your attention to one thing
which is sort of you know some years
back the whole bandwidth between you and
the computer was essentially what you
could type on the keyboard yeah and then
fast forward till today where I track in
watching your face thinking about the
megabytes per second going into the
system
watching you doing something yeah and
there opens the door for learning much
more about you than you ever wanted
someone to know about you or maybe not
who knows that I think that that's
really where we are going where where
the bandwidth between the systems and
its users becomes so massive that we
start learning about behavior much
faster the system learns about our
behavior much faster than than we would
like it to yeah so I'll also add to that
I think it's easy for us to sort of
imagine where
technology's gonna go and want to
immediately jump to Oh everything's
gonna be automated the humans won't even
be needed and the reality is I think a
lot of what we're gonna see in the near
term is incredible technology augmented
human interactions because there are
just certain things where human human
interactions are really meaningful and
are really important and that empathy is
not going to be automated away anytime
in the near future and so at least a
theme that I've been seeing in some of
the investments we've been making is how
can we make some of these important
people interactions just much much more
efficient with the data we have imagine
that's what the ideal background I mean
you have to think about the design of
this right the interaction with data and
looking for some of those kind of human
touch there's a lot of focus or a
concern in healthcare that you know the
robot is going to take a replace your
dog the doctor and you know I'm in a
soirée I or I like to call ia
intelligence augmentation is coming so
you know radiology pathology
Sebastian's done with Rheumatology so I
don't think those gonna replace your
dermatologist radiologist without
completely but we need to figure out the
user interfaces because physicians now
if you guys are building smart systems
no doctor wants to be overwhelmed with
raw data how do you interface with that
how do you then give more time for the
human component cuz we spend twice as
much time typing medical records and
feeding the billing machines then then
human face to face as much as we'd like
to so there's a whole design element
piece to manage the information to
augment the clinician or to take a nurse
in a rural village and give them the
upskill them to be what a cardiologist
Stanford could do today they would need
to teach class and design thinking for
AI or for data will be a very special
nano degree I want to switch to a little
bit more practical in terms of you know
data analysis in general and the skills
that our students are learning you know
do you see data analysis of something
only data analysts do so our students
and data analysts nanodegree program or
you know our machine learning anna
degree program or is this something that
you know broadly anyone should be able
to tap into how specific of a skill is
this gosh well I'll just say that
learning how to interpret and do
something important with data
is what makes data meaningful and
valuable so so many people love to talk
about you know we've got all this data
but it really isn't helpful until you
can tease out the little nuances that do
make it valuable and then do something
with that and somebody has to own that
job and it's a highly iterative process
to be able to do that and figure it out
and so there's a lot a lot of need for
for people who have that dedication and
determination so I guess I mean we often
get the question of the confluence of
like where does data analysts and who
are just data scientists start where
does data engineering and machine
learning and all of that go how would
you guys describe sort of that spectrum
and in those steps on the medical side
we just you know start with blood
pressure heart rate respiratory all
these basic data forms that we can still
calculate and look at a patient to
figure out whether they're sick or not
but now there's all these new forms
again from your wearable exhaust from
your from your Amazon Alexa it to your
omics and I think it's a huge
opportunity for the folks here to be
smartly interacting and and we need to
integrate data science into medical
school we get very little of that piece
so that we're learning how to make sense
of that famously Google or verily health
now is doing the baseline trial to start
collect and from ten thousand volunteers
what their digital exhaust is what their
genomics what their outcomes are so we
can learn to synthesize that and use it
in a clinical sense but I think we need
to educate the clinicians and each of us
as consumers and patients to hopefully
own manipulate and share new data new
forms it won't just be I'm an oncologist
how many months a patient survives on a
new drug but maybe what the quality of
life is maybe that could be picked up in
a whole new way so how we can speed up
clinical trials and integrate new forms
of data to form that as actionable
information it'll be important so here
it's like it you know there's definitely
industry specific almost skills right
but for our students you know in terms
of the pathway I think that's what
they're kind of asking for what is the
pathway to to become a Danny okay
where does data analyst start where is
how does how far can the path go and
what's the differences right in those
steps I I think it's a funnel that goes
from analytics to data science to
machine learning I also think that
have realized over the last 10 years or
so that it's it's more and more a matter
of automation yeah the times where an
analyst could write a report and submit
it to some manager and they would look
at it and make decisions based on that I
think those times are rapidly changing I
think that direct feedback from from
from customer browsing on your website
to the to ordering of components in your
logistics in your supply chain is being
automated there's no longer people
sitting and deciding how many chips are
we gonna purchase for the next
generation a Kindle device yeah it's
it's it's that is automated that is a
very rapidly advanced you know pipeline
of data and I think that it's very
important if you are if you're on the
analytic analytics in the data science
space to understand that what you do
doesn't end with a spreadsheet or
tableau presentation it's it's it kind
of needs to lead into pipelines into
processing into automation I'll add to
that there's a theme and the investing
world as well there for a while there
were all of these dashboard companies
you know we can find this data and we
will show it to you and then it's on you
to act on it and and obviously for many
reasons that it just puts the onus back
on you to figure out then how to execute
and move forward so automation and
figuring out how to act on these those
important insights is the key to the
companies that end up doing really well
fantastic point I mean what kind of data
companies on that front are you guys
looking to invest in where what are the
problems that you're looking to solve
with with data so what companies aren't
using data I guess is the the inverse of
that question I think every single
company and no matter what sector it is
is really tying into some amount of data
and then acting on it and so I really
honestly I think it's you know I can't
think of a sector where there's not data
that that we're taking advantage of I
think the issue is that now we can go so
much deeper and so the level of
automation and the level of ease with
which we then get that information and
then can act so much more efficiently we
can make
more of an impact you know on everything
from you know an enterprise solution to
a consumer solution so it's all across
the investing ecosystem wonderful last
question for each of you
the theme is lifelong learning today
what are you each hoping to learn next
Danny all right
arts yeah yeah actually what am i
interested in is how can you how can you
help the artist how can you help it can
be a graphics artist with tools to take
away some of the more tedious work how
can you help the squib Rider with great
ideas for plot how can you how can you
help artist people using data to
literally write scripts right yeah yeah
but how to make it more creative I would
love to learn that learn how to be
creative yeah okay I feel so lucky
because my job is all about pick a
sector dive deep and learn and so I've
done everything from spending a ton of
time on the smart home to we were
talking a little bit earlier about how
inspired and how changed my life has
been from just some really basic
nutritional changes that I was able to
make and so an area that I am super
passionate about is how can we with data
go direct to consumers direct to people
and really make an impact on their their
well-being in a way that you know is
super cost-effective and data-driven I
guess one of things but I'm about
learning is maybe also helping catalyze
folks in healthcare and beyond to start
connect all these convergent dots I run
a program called exponential medicine
and the most interesting new healthcare
solutions and products from apps to
devices to to chat BOTS are being built
by folks like yourself it may not have
been traditional healthcare folks but
see a medical issue or healthcare issue
and and help solve that whether it's how
to understand your nutritional data or
how to connect your smart home to detect
if grandma falls down or not and
personally I'm trying to figure how to
connect all those dots and help catalyze
new thinking wonderful
I know I've learned a lot and
I have my next creative design
nanodegree kind of planned but thank you
all I know I'm looking at time and I
don't know if I have time for questions
because we're running a little bit out
of time so thank you all and I will be
staying up here okay
[Applause]